what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are in kind of a weird spot
we have about six weeks until we need to
upload the return of Thanos after a
second death which goes directly into
the pre loo to Thanos quests which goes
directly into Infinity Gauntlet yes I
have infinity gauntlet part eight yes I
have two Anna's quest parts one into I
originally had to take them down for
copyright reasons but that's since been
sorted out so at this point I'm just
waiting to re-upload those which means
that we kind of have like six weeks to
kill and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna upload earth x we're gonna do the
earth x series now or at least just the
earth x story I'm gonna test this so I'm
gonna see how you guys respond to it
because I don't know if people will
really enjoy it or if people are
definitely like a small handful of
people that are really even like
remotely interested in it but earth X is
really really good earth X is actually
the story that basically deals with the
answer to the question what would happen
if everybody on earth had superpowers
what would happen to the Marvel Universe
and how would the heroes deal with it as
it was basically a dystopian future
story and it's actually really really
interesting now there is a prelude in
terms of how all this took place and
what all happened in terms of how
everyone gained powers all that kind of
stuff we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it for right now I'm not gonna
cover the pre loot I'm gonna do that at
the end I'm gonna make you guys wait but
what this initially does is this picks
up with Captain America Steve Rogers and
this basically tells the origin story of
his character and that's something that
I want you guys to notice with this
earth X the way this initially picks up
is the origin stories for the characters
are largely the same they're larger the
kind of stories were familiar with
there's small changes here and there but
largely for the most part the origin
stories are still the same for example
Steve Rogers took the Super Soldier
Serum and became Captain America he
eventually went on to fight against the
Red Skull during World War two and the
various you know German powers and so on
and so forth and then what we ended up
having was the drone plane explosion now
here's a big difference between Earth X
and the main Marvel Universe when it
comes to the drone plane explosion the
way this originally happened this was
done by Baron Zemo but there's nothing
to indicate the Baron Zemo is actually
here we're kind of left to believe he is
but it's really one of those things
where it's traced back to the Red Skull
and so because of that we get largely
just kind of assume the Red Skull was
behind the whole thing which he kind of
was when it came to the original drone
plane crash the difference here is that
in the original crash
Captain America fell down into the ocean
he was basically you know frozen and ice
for however many years and then Bucky
bar and survived the explosion and was
captured by the Russians and turned into
the Winter Soldier and this story the
indication is that didn't happen
Barnes nod he's gone he's no longer part
of the equation here now following this
what ended up happening is we basically
had Captain America who came back the
Red Skull of course who rose to
prominence once again we had the other
story where the Red Skull gained a
cosmic cube the difference of what's not
necessarily covered directly in this
instead it's actually covered in the
backup pages it's kind of like an
exchange between the two characters who
were chronicling this whole thing what
we ended up finding out is that Captain
America somewhere along the line killed
the Red Skull and so the Red Skull is
basically dead or at least that's the
indication and so what it does is kind
of jump to the modern-day now again this
story is kind of being given to us by
two individuals and I'll reveal who
those are once we get to the end of this
whole thing but what we end up doing
here is picking up with like the return
of the Inhumans
and the Inhumans had basically left
earth for reasons that we'll find out
later on in this story but the Inhumans
showing back off really comes by way of
the royal marriage between Luna and the
prince now
Luna is the daughter of Crystal and
Quicksilver if you don't know who
crystal is not a great big huge deal
she's basically just a member of the
inhuman royal family and then of course
Quicksilver the son of Magneto and
Marvel Comics in the main Marvel
Universe they did have a child named
Luna what this story does is take place
around 20 years in the future so and
basically say we end up having the
Inhumans making the return in order to
kind of you know engage in this royal
marriage the problem is that when the
Inhumans show back up everything has
really gone to pot Attilan is just kind
of left in shambles and no one really
knows we're like super-powered people
are at least they don't know we're
super-powered people aren't we're like
The Avengers or the x-men or any of
those folks are at and so what they end
up doing is taking up residence and
traveling directly to New York in order
to figure out what's going on so what we
do is we basically join up with what
seems to be just a city of New York
that's just filled with all these
super-powered beings but what's
happening here is there's kind of a
reshaping of things taking place to a
degree in the sense that what you have
is this kind of Hydra alien now this is
one of those weird scenarios because in
the main Marvel Universe Hydra basically
broke off from the Germans it was
founded by Baron von Strucker his
ideologies were starkly different from
the Germans and that's one of the
reasons why he became an enemy of that
group at the same time a lying himself
at the hand and then just kind of going
off and doing his own thing because of
this in Earth X there really is no Hydra
in the sense that we're familiar with
with Baron von Strucker instead there's
just kind of like the Hydra organism and
what this thing is done is somewhere
along the line begun bonding itself to
various people one of them
notable being Jennifer Walters she-hulk
and what it does is it basically kind of
takes over people in their entirety and
brings them into a kind of hive mind
collective much like the actual like
Hydra organization itself something else
to notice here is that Steve Rogers as
we see him is vastly different than the
Captain America that were used to one of
the things that had taken place here is
that when Steve Rogers is basically
being Captain America the country had
rallied under him now much like in the
main Marvel Universe in Captain America
number 250 I think Steve Rogers ran for
president of the United States where the
very least was offered the opportunity
to run for president of the United
States the difference is that unlike the
main Marvel Universe where he ran in
this story he doesn't run he actually
rejects the whole thing and the issue
with this is that the American people
see him as rejecting America and so as a
result Captain America loses popularity
and that's one of the reasons why his
outfits so tattered he looks kind of
like you know like he's a man that's
just struggled over and over and over
again he's really seen some things not
only that we end up finding out that
he's not necessarily paired up with
Falcon instead Falcon had actually been
absorbed into this Hydra organism
whatever it is instead he's paired up
with Wyatt Wingfoot now Wyatt Wingfoot
is a care to the dates all the way back
to the early days of the Fantastic Four
so if you haven't heard about him don't
feel bad because in truth he hasn't been
a relevant character for something like
50 years but Wyatt Wingfoot was
basically kind of like a like a mascot
for the Fantastic Four to a degree he
was a close friend he would help them on
missions different things like that but
he had no real powers he was just kind
of a guy who was there and so the idea
is that he basically becomes Red Wing at
least that's the name that's given to
him he kind of becomes the new Falcon so
that's what's pretty pretty insane here
because we end up having the actual
Falcon basically speaking to Captain
America by way of this you know Hydra
entity saying hey look you have to join
us you should show up you should become
part of our group and we're Captain
America and Wyatt kind of fight against
these forces the group has suddenly met
with the arrival of Cyclops and this is
an older Cyclops so he's older he's
great he's not part of the x-men you
know as far as we're aware the x-men
don't really seem to exist instead what
we're told is that somewhere along the
line the x-men had effectively disbanded
and Charles Xavier had died so the
group's not really there anymore
following that we switch over to a Peter
Parker and Peter Parker again kind of a
guy who's in his 40s you know basically
an aging guy is told by Sargent Luke
Cage hey look you have to get out of
here Tony Stark is implementing one of
these purges of course you also have may
Parker who's kind of watching the events
unfold wearing
Spider outfit but that's when we end up
finding out here that this is attempt by
the Hydra entity to basically infiltrate
New York and conquer the city in its
entirety is a repeating pattern it seems
to happen almost every single day and
every single day Tony Stark sends out
these life model decoy Avengers and they
go through and they quote-unquote purge
you know this Hydra entity and basically
running out of town until it comes back
and tries to repeat the same process
again but that's the nature of things
because what we end up having is Steve
Rogers who is basically able to break
away a piece of the clothing of one of
the individuals who've been brought in
by this Hydra entity and Steve Rogers
reveals that what's on this this this
cloth is a Red Skull insignia now this
is where things really begin to get
crazy what we end up doing here is
actually following up with these two
individuals who are chronically in the
Fantastic Four
now the Fantastic Four origin is exactly
the way that always was the idea that
Reed Richards was more obsessed with
like the pursuit of knowledge you know
different things like that which led him
taking Ben Grimm and Susan storm and
Johnny Storm onto a spacecraft they flew
into space
they were bombarded by cosmic rays and
they gained their powers the difference
here is that somewhere along the line
Reed Richards had basically discovered
the nature of vibranium in the sense
that when he was presumably invited by
Black Panther to Wakanda and Reed sort
of deduced that vibranium was
extraterrestrial in nature and so what
he began doing was kind of setting up
these transportation tubes that were
designed to basically eliminate the
entire need for energy across the world
using vibranium as a source and that's
really all we get because what we end up
doing is picking up with the Inhumans
when they basically traveled to Yancy
Street to where Ben Grim's located at of
course with Adam warlock and hizmet
rather who are essentially just kind of
leaving the house of Ben Grimm those are
guys who don't know uh you saw kismet in
guardians of the galaxy - that was the
chick who was like you know the leader
of whatever that group was who was all
gold though the whole basis behind this
was you know when we talked about Adam
warlock before we kind of revealed the
idea that Adam warlock was created by a
group called the hive who were basically
held in on creating like the perfect
being and we're out of Morlock
essentially he made his escape turned
against the hive took off you know for
parts unknown and then you know his
whole story unfolded in terms of his you
know inclusion with Thanos and different
things like that that what was also
created was a being called her which
basically became kismet and they were
designed to be mates and so what this
does is essentially revealed that the
two of them have found one another and
they have effectively become mates not
only that what we end up doing is
picking up with Ben
and his family now the cool thing about
this is that Ben Grimm is married to
Alicia masters and Alicia masters has
basically gained powers which is to say
the ability to bring things to life now
this is important because Alicia masters
as originally a woman who is blind but
was a gifted sculptor and what this
meant was that she could basically
sculpt anything she could make you know
things look almost real life and then
interned with the power she has now
bring them to life and that's how the
family of Ben Grimm basically comes to
fruition the actions of Alicia masters
allows her to take the clay and then
molded into like children basically of
Ben Grimm and herself and then bring
them to life all these different
artifacts these things that you see here
the moldings of spider-man The Moorings
of Captain America the mohrís of dr.
Doom's head all that's done by Alicia
masters and it's pretty cool because
while they're all sitting down around
the dinner table the question that comes
from the Inhumans is where are the
Fantastic Four one of the world's going
on here well what we end up finding out
is that somewhere along the line during
this 20 year window dr. doom had
essentially launched a campaign due to
the fact that there was a huge meeting
between the United Nations and it was
dr. Doom's attempt to effectively
capture the world's food resources to
essentially say if you control resources
you control the world and dr. doom had
actually brought name with us
submariners who aside by arguing that
when humanity takes into account what
they're going to do with this global
food shortage at no point will they take
into account Atlantis instead they will
think only about what benefits the
surface world and so we effectively
joined dr. doom in order to curtail that
whole discussion in the first place and
so as a result the Fantastic Four
responded Captain America responded so
on and so forth and it led him to a
pretty significant battle between the
two groups but where Johnny Storm went
to try to stop Namor the Submariner
Namor basically killed him he stabbed
him with his Trident and in response
Franklin Richards freaked out he
basically used his powers of
reality-warping to condemn they were the
Submariner to burn on one half of his
body for all eternity
the only way for him to basically not
burn on one half is to jump down into
the oceans and that's kind of where it
keeps him at the moment it keeps him
underwater so that he's not literally
burning on one side but because of the
fact that Susan storm and Johnny Storm
were so close as brother and sister
Susan storm loses it as well and so what
ends up happening is she chases after
dr. doom immediately goes after him he
leads her into a trap and then detonates
the entire facility killing dr. doom
himself and Susan storm and so that all
that's really left here is Franklin
Richards were given no indication
valaria Richards the daughter of
of read and Susan is actually alive and
instead all we have is just Ben Grimm
and Reid and that's where things begin
to get kind of crazy because the
question is asked well then whatever
happened to Reed Richards you know where
in the world is Reed Richards at and so
what we end up learning here is that
Reed Richards in his attempt to kind of
deal with the gravity of the situation
but to also huge the almost limitless
resources of Victor Von Doom base adalat
variant he basically took on dooms armor
and then took up residence in Latveria
and so Reed Richards basically became
Doctor Doom and it's really cool it's
such an awesome idea it's such an
awesome concept but Reed has really
overcome with the whole situation is
just kind of sitting there and almost on
the verge of giving up because what he
does is speak with Tony Stark a day
after day in terms of trying to find a
way to figure out what went on with
regards to everybody gaining powers how
everybody got abilities in the first
place all they know is it has something
to do with the overload of vibranium but
nobody really knows how they simply know
that Reed built this massive system the
vibranium was used as a conduit
basically as an energy source that
somehow it overloaded something went
wrong and everybody gained powers across
the world and so the idea of Reed is you
know really to kind of like find a cure
it's to find a way to fix this but
notice this whole thing and this is
something that I want you guys to keep
in mind notice this when it comes to
this whole scenario
it's superheroes trying to return things
to the status quo well the world was
better when only we had powers the world
was not better when everyone had powers
it's one of those interesting things
it's kind of like a fear of change in
terms of how that whole thing happens
and so it is cool the issue is that
Reed's been trying to figure it out all
this time but hasn't come to a
conclusion he's just kind of stuck in
this rut of dealing with this emotional
crushing you know the fact that he lost
Susan storm the fact that he lost Johnny
storm the fact that Ben Grimm kind of
abandoned the Fantastic Four ideology
went off started his own family kind of
left it all behind that's really where
all this is kind of coming from for the
character of Reed and so what we end up
doing is switching over to this sort of
carnival that's going on in terms of
this group can you see you know do you
want to come see the new daredevil can
you kill the new daredevil that's really
the whole idea and they subject him to a
wide array of different forms of torture
you know whether it's fire something
along those lines and this guy survives
each and every time and so the result is
that where he's supposed to basically be
set on fire and then impaled and that's
really supposed to be about it instead
the entire scenario is met by this like
massive amount of people who all show up
at the same time you know a lot of these
like superheroes who just kind of pop up
the scene and basically say hey look you
guys are all under the control of the
Red Skull now this all belongs to us
everything belongs to the skull either
you can ally with this or you can die
that's really the only ultimatum it's
given to them but again it's crazy so a
couple things that I want to I want to
kind of wrap into this a couple things
that I want to discuss about this for a
second the first is the state of
government so the United States
government in this story has effectively
collapsed there's no more Congress
there's no more White House there's
basically Norman Osborn who's
essentially president he has absolute
power and everything's basically run by
corporations it's really run by like
Norman Osborn himself and so if it
doesn't have a financial incentive then
no one cares none of the court none of
the corporation's care you know and so
again it's it's pretty wild in terms of
how this whole thing unfold the story
only ever gets better from here it just
it gets absolutely bonkers oh my god
then you get into Universe X and then
you get into paradise X dude I died
alive I love like I think Earth X is the
best of them but like universe X is
actually pretty solid like it's it's
free all dude what'd you guys get - the
Galactus reveal oh man dude you guys are
gonna freak out when we get to the
reveal of Galactus at the end of the
story dude okay those are guys who read
that when I saw that almost like oh my
god Gordon do not show people who
Galactus is in Earth X if I see a
Galactus Pan will pop up on here there's
gonna man you're gonna be in a world of
hurt like I'm really excited to see the
Galactus reveal oh dude I'm so dude I'm
actually trying to read the comments on
the Galactus reveal okay so we are
continuing on with Earth X and god I
love earth X so much I love this story
it's so cool it's such a cool idea a
dystopian future in Marvel Comics where
everything in terms of like history is
still the same but like one event
happened and change the future of
everything
it's like Marvel ruins Marvel ruins ask
the question what would happen if people
actually you know if they actually gain
their powers in the real world were
actually exposed to the accidents the
gains in their powers in the real world
and it all turns out really dark like it
gets it gets really messed up but again
with the first story one of the big
things that was going on with Captain
America was that he had like turned down
the Office of the President of the
United States right and so because of
that like the American people kind of
turned their backs on him they're just
sort of like well then if you don't want
to lead us then we don't want to be a
part of what you have going on and he
kind of just became not really a pariah
so much is just an outlier he was just a
guy who was there and then this was
compounded
the fact that for some reason somewhere
along the line suddenly everybody's sort
of developing powers and so it became
kind of crazy because now Captain
America was obsolete because everybody
had power so there was really no one for
Captain America to really rescue aside
from those who were may be injured or
infirm or something along those lines
but a majority of people could just save
themselves but the whole idea was that
when he was dealing with the Hydra which
is basically just kind of like a space
organism that showed up on earth and it
taken over you know like Jennifer
Walters she-hulk and a handful of other
people and was trying to spread itself
outside of New York that one of the
individuals who have been taken was
wearing a Red Skull shirt and that kind
of set Captain America on this path of
trying to find the newly returned Red
Skull as he believed him to be and so
what this does is it leads us to
California and again this is kind of
crazy because like New York itself
California that's basically fallen and
that's one of the themes that you guys
are gonna notice here for the most part
where we would believe that like the
rise of superpowers on earth would lead
to a kind of Age of Heroes in the sense
that it would basically be this place
where you'll be almost utopian where
would be like a higher state of being
and everything would be better and so on
and so forth instead it became this kind
of land
do as you please to quote V for Vendetta
and so the result is that people just
kind of do whatever it is that they want
to and it gave rise to petty warlords
because for those individuals who gained
powers but never took the steps
necessary to learn what it meant to have
power
they've just suddenly realized they can
do anything they want to and so leading
up into California itself again like New
York it's basically collapsed just kind
of like this place where things happen
and stuff goes on and that's really
about it and a petty warlord has
effectively risen to power now what is
up happening here is in the middle of
all this namor the sub-mariner returns I
remember we talked about this in the
last video name of the Submariner had
killed Johnny Storm when Namor had
allied himself with Doctor Doom and a
fight broke out between these two groups
in the vergis this group in the
Fantastic Four and so the result was
that with the death of Johnny Storm
Franklin Richards freaked out and he
basically uses reality-warping powers
and forced one half of the body of name
where the Submariner to burn anytime he
wasn't in water and so as a result he
basically makes his presence here in
kind of pops up because people are
essentially infiltrating the Seas and
they're going through and kind of doing
whatever they want and he really kind of
said get suited to be like an affront
more or less like breaking into a man's
house that kind of a thing and so the
result is that we actually move from
that and switch over to Peter Parker
with his daughter who's become venom now
I want you to notice something here and
this is something that I thought about
talking about in the last video but I
thought it would be more pertinent to
talk about here Peter Parker
is nothing like he used to be the whole
nature of Peter Parker when it comes to
him being spider-man historically
speaking in Marvel Comics is yes he has
his ups and downs he has his good times
in his bad times but the idea is that
for the most part Peter Parker is
optimistic he really sees like the glass
half-full and because of that he's very
much one of these characters it's kind
of like a bright shining star in Marvel
Comics that I would necessarily say
people idolize but he certainly
brightens up a story a little bit if
it's going in a darker direction but in
this instance Peter Parker's cynical
he's really kind of like you know
there's no need for us here anymore
there's no need for us to be superheroes
and that's kind of funny because it
almost indicates that Peter Parker's
perspective of himself in the world
walks the knife's edge Peter Parker sees
himself as relevant only so far as
there's someone for him to protect now
he also of course has you know was
married somewhere along the line hence
the birth of Mayday Parker we can
probably assume it was Mary Jane Watson
I don't believe we're explicitly told at
least not that I recall but the fact
remains here that somewhere along the
line the daughter of Peter Parker gained
the venoms Simeon and this is kind of
interesting because Peter's initial
stance is no matter how hard you try in
the end it will take you over but the
indication here is that made a partner
is actually in control of the Venom
symbiote not only that Peter and his
daughter are basically not really
estranged so much as they're not really
close to each other they're not like the
kind of relationship you would expect
with a father and a daughter you know
kind of providing these pearls of wisdom
teaching his daughter how to become a
woman how to function as a superhero and
that's what's so ironic about this is
because in a lot of ways Peter was one
of the first he was one of the first
superheroes to rise to prominence in
Marvel Comics and so if ever there were
a person to basically be tutored under
it's Peter Parker and so that's what's
so ironic about this is Peter being one
of the really kind of like the face of
Marvel Comics one of the foremost heroes
is no longer a hero he's just an aging
guy that just kind of exists he just
kind of floats from one day to next and
he will until he dies it's the saddest
thing to see a person who exists but
doesn't really live so again from here
we switch back over to Reed Richards now
again what we talked about in the last
video is that Reed had basically taken
over Latveria he had taken over the
mantle of Doctor Doom not in the sense
that he'd become like a villain it's
unlike Reed Richards put on the outfit
of a Victor Von oedema was like I am now
the new Doctor Doom he just kind of
taken up residence there in Liberia and
the whole basis behind this was you know
the death of the Fantastic Four
basically you know a susanin and Johnny
Storm truly the rise of superpowers
among the entirety of the Planet Earth
all that rests on the shoulders of of
Reed Richards and the reason
this is because what Reid had done is he
had basically accessed or learned about
vibranium inside of Wakanda and because
he and Black Panther were such close
friends and because there was just like
an energy shortage across the world what
ended up happening is Reid had actually
gone to Wakanda petitioned you know
T'Challa used vibranium and intended to
basically turn sound ways to convert
sound waves into energy light and
different things like that that could in
turn basically power the world what it
meant is that the world would achieve
like a higher state of being it would
achieve a greater enlightenment humanity
wouldn't have to focus on whether or not
people in their countries have enough to
eat or whether or not they have
electricity or they have running water
or anything like that
all those would be a foregone conclusion
that was ultimately the idea of Reid but
notice this this falls in line with the
nature of Reid now in truth the idea of
like trying to fix the problem of
everything that didn't come until almost
a decade after this story was written
but that was a natural progression when
Jonathan Hickman introduced that into
Reed Richards it wasn't a paradigm shift
for his character it wasn't a total 180
a man who's obsessed with science a man
who's obsessed with fixing the world's
problems the most natural progression is
to solve the problem of everything but
where Reid is you know a guy who's known
for science the truth of the matter is
it read as a slave to science and so in
this instance when he was trying to
solve the world's problems because it
went awry he's basically kind of stuck
in his own you know inner hell more or
less of trying to figure out the
solution what went wrong where did I
screw up what happened you know that's
really all it is that's the governing
factor that controls his life what
happened what went wrong and what can be
done to fix it and he lives his life day
in and day out trying to find an answer
to that question he's literally governed
by his own mistakes and so the result is
that when he basically offers his
explanation when he says look somewhere
along the line something happened and
there was some kind of an explosion and
this energy this vibranium energy was
basically just dispersed throughout the
entirety of the planet Earth and
suddenly people started gaining powers
the factor is what constant because
Reid's
Reid's idea is that the vibranium energy
caused it but we know that's not the
case
vibranium doesn't give people powers it
doesn't work that way and so the result
is that something had to happen
vibranium was the means by which it
could be transmitted but like something
had to give people powers and the
question is what was that thing and
that's what Reid hasn't figured out yet
and so were the Inhumans kind of talk
about if we had enough time we could
probably figure it out when Reid says
the catalyst he used to achieve this was
vibranium son
had to start turning and the reason why
is because somewhere along the line the
Inhumans abandon earth when everybody
started getting powers the Inhumans left
there was no reason for them to be there
anymore
the Inhumans left to basically colonize
the new world and to start over again
but when they got through they
discovered another world where basically
it had been totally destroyed and
obliterated but the people who inhabited
that world were encased in a kind of
material of sorts but they were still
alive they were just kind of in a state
of suspended animation and where the
Inhumans had considered rescuing them
what they discovered was that the source
of this explosion at least it seemed was
vibranium and so that's really kind of
what they bring to the table is look if
what you did was used vibranium and
somehow that in turn gave everybody
powers in one form or another meaning
that you basically use it as a energy
source and dispersed it across the world
you've doomed the planet because we
don't necessarily know exactly what it
was that caused that planet to erupt but
what we do know is that vibranium was
tapped into it somehow now if you know
the truth about what happened do not
spoil it I swear to God I will
I like punishments will be handed down
swift and harsh but it's cool this is
one of those things were it's like
everybody has a piece of the puzzle but
it turns out the puzzle they're solving
is not the actual puzzle they're looking
for so that's what's cool about this
whole thing but switching back to name
with a submariner the whole situation
with him again
like he's just kind of like rallying
these folks up and that's traditional
name war stuff I mean one thing to bear
in mind is that name or an Aquaman are
very similar when it comes to that
regard I mean name war appeared before
Aquaman but they weren't Aquaman a very
you know similar in that regard in the
sense that it is one of those scenarios
where their allegiance is to the sea you
know Aquaman name of the Submariner you
know they've been part of their own
respective superhero teams they mores
been an Avenger Aquaman's been part of
the Justice League but when the question
is asked if you have to choose between
like your superhero team and the
superheroes of Earth and like Atlantis
which one do you guys pick and they
always choose Atlantis every single time
without fail they never they never hit
that Marcus I'm a king first and a
superhero second and that's the role
that name with a submariner place the
problem with this is that while he's
basically going on a rampage in New York
and Captain America and in you know
Wyatt Wingfoot are watching it all
unfold suddenly Namor stops he simply
just stops and calms down and that's it
and just descends down to the surface
and slowly starts walking towards some
person and that's what we end up finding
out the red skull is not the red skull
it's just some teenage kid who is
how manage to take the entirety of
California and place the entire state
under his control now at this point we
kind of go on to a side mission of sorts
with Reid and the Inhumans and the
reason why is because remember when it
comes to the Inhumans the whole reason
that they're here they're supposed to
basically be finding a prince of sorts a
person who's supposed to be marrying
Luna the daughter of Quicksilver and
crystal as soon as they find that person
presumably they would just leave they
would say okay cool it's time for us to
go again and they would just kind of
bail out and so the whole idea for Reid
is to basically you know offer some
measure of help again kind of feeding
into the idea of him trying to solve his
own problems calm these inner demons so
to speak but what it would also do is
help to give some insight potentially
into how it was everybody got powers and
so the result of this is that where Reid
initially sits down and says it seems
almost impossible to differentiate
between the Inhumans and basically
mutated humans suddenly dawns on him to
grab cerebro you know now of course most
way everybody knows who saw you know
what cerebro is the device that Xavier
used to basically locate mutants on
earth to differentiate between humans
and then those who had an X gene but it
is kind of cool because reads responses
what we can modify it and we can
basically use that to find like any
humans and then from those Inhumans we
can sort out who this prince is that
you're supposed to be locating and who
it is is supposed to marry Luna now at
this point we switch back over to
Captain America again and this is really
really cool it's like one of the coolest
moments in the whole story because one
is up happening here is Captain America
basically approaches this young kid and
essentially says you can't do this now
remember Captain America is basically
holding on to a dead ideology he's
holding on to the realm of freedom
basically saying people should have the
right to live their lives as they see
fit but that's what you're seeing here
people achieved ultimate freedom when it
came to everybody having superpowers and
instead of saying okay we should do this
responsibility people just descended
into madness and chaos so sure people
had freedom and they use that freedom to
destroy themselves and so because of
that Captain America is just kind of a
relic
he's an archaic thing he's not relevant
anymore and so when he approaches this
kid and starts talking to him the
initial response of the kid is hey look
I can do anything I want to and that's
when it starts to dawn on Wyatt Wingfoot
in Captain America that this kids power
is mind control and that's what he's
doing he's mind controlling every single
person in this vicinity and has them all
under his command what he's also doing
is effectively building an army because
like so many petty warlords that exist
in the United States right now what you
have are people who realize I've got
powers and I can use these powers to
give mice
even more power and that's what a ton of
people are doing but we're Captain
America's steps in he goes to attack
this kid suddenly he gets a flashback
and he sees Bucky Barnes and that's the
power of this kid notices this kids
power is almost identical to like
mastermind jason wyngarde now that's
kind of one of those funny such funny
situations when it comes to like powers
and Marvel Comics in a lot of ways a lot
of them are basically identical they're
just used in different ways or they have
little caveats the power of jason
wyngarde is to manipulate the five
senses whatever you can like see touch
smell taste in here he can manipulate it
so he can take away your sense of taste
he can take away your sense of smell or
he can make you believe that if you're
eating a piece of pizza that you're
actually tasting a lemon there's all
kinds of different things that he can do
with you not the effect of him doing
that is the exact same effect as if
Charles Xavier controls your mind and
made you believe that you were somewhere
else it all has it all kind of comes out
to the same thing well the fact remains
you know kind of going off this tangent
in this story Bucky Barnes again you
know is basically dead he's long since
been dead
there is no Winter Soldier Bucky Barnes
died he's been dead all this time
because of the cool thing about this is
that in this instance Captain America is
literally hallucinating that he's in
World War two and that he's trying to
save Bucky Barnes but where he starts to
freak out and then eventually snaps out
of it wai-wait foot is basically taken
over and then this huge army of of Red
Skull just kind of descends down onto
Captain America and the result is that
were they're all screaming and they're
all basically saying we don't want to do
this you have to help us we don't want
to be the ones that are doing this we
don't mean to hurt you Captain America
has to effectively abandon everyone and
run away and that's what's so screwed up
about that it's Captain America who
effectively walks out on humanity yet
again and this was kind of crazy is
because we would expect Captain America
to stay there and fight but it's also
one of those things up run away live to
fight another day but find a way to
bring this down and set the world back
to rights and that's kind of the cool
thing about Captain America in this
instance but at this point we basically
jump back to New York
essentially with I think it's I want to
say it's Betty Ross uh who was mutated
and ended up you know becoming like this
demon looking thing this crazy-looking
thing and where she's initially set upon
by Hydra they're met by the arrival of
the Incredible Hulk and Bruce Banner now
this is kind of interesting as far as
I'm aware I don't believe we're given an
explanation as to why it is the
Incredible Hulk and Bruce Banner are two
distinctly different people although now
that I think about it I think we are
given an explanation I mean it's not in
this particular part of the story but I
think we are given an explanation
interim
like how the whole thing with manner and
the hoof works the way this works is
that banners basically blonde and he
sees through the eyes of the Incredible
Hulk so it's kind of cool uh but it is
an interesting scenario because
basically hoaxes almost like this giant
gorilla form which it's kind of cool to
be honest but the whole idea is to
essentially show up to basically go
visit you know Doctor Strange in the
sanctum sanctorum but when they get
there when they get to where the
sorcerer supreme is at of course they
are met by Wang but what we end up
discovering is that Doctor Strange isn't
here instead the current sorcerer
supreme is the niece of Dormammu also
known as Clea ok so we are continuing
our discussion on earth X and again like
Earth X God you guys really seem to
enjoy I love it too it's it's a really
really cool take on like an alternate
universe and Marvel Comics but what this
part does is we initially pick up with
the Asgardians now this is kind of a
cool thing and the main Marvel Universe
the Asgardians are just sort of
attributed to gods who exist in a
different dimension and that's really
about it what earth x does is it makes
them a lot more grounded and tangible
now one of the big things that people do
is they kind of make the mistake of
taking the earth X story of the
Asgardians and believing that's the main
Marvel Universe story they're not
exactly identical instead in earth X
what we end up finding out here is that
the Asgardians are basically aliens and
they derive themselves from from
shapeshifters but the funny thing is
that because they were shapeshifters
they had no true identities they
eventually arrived on earth and when
they did they encountered humanity and
humanity gave the Asgardians forms and
so it's kind of interesting because
while they are perceived as gods in the
eyes of humanity and they operate as
gods in the eyes of humanity they're
actually prisoners of humanity the story
actually hits on the nature of Ragnarok
that's one of the questions is asked
here won't Ragnarok be the end times of
the Asgardians but the reason why
Ragnarok will exist is not because it's
a totally separate set of circumstances
that involve Surtur and all these things
and will inevitably happen to the
Asgardians outside of the fates of
humanity instead Ragnarok is defined as
the end times of the Asgardians meaning
Ragnarok will come when humanity ends
when the world is destroyed and the
reason why is because when the world is
destroyed humanity will be destroyed
with it and there'll be no one left to
give these various as Guardians any real
appearance or anything there'll be no
one left to basically guide them on what
they should be and so the result is that
they will most likely just kind of
self-destruct or they'll just go on to
become something else but regardless but
the Asgardians quote-unquote
effectively come to an end and that's
kind of the cool thing here it takes
this origin story kind of turns it
around a little bit it shifts it around
but everything else remains intact
Thor was eventually banished from Asgard
nor to learn humility Loki was the
trickster Odin was the king of all the
Asgardians all that kind of stuff you
know it's cool because a lot of that
history still remains intact but at this
point we switch back over to Latveria
basically to castle doom now again
because of the fact that Reed Richards
had been masquerading as Victor Von Doom
and the Inhumans had arrived back on
earth looking for the husband of Luna
the daughter of a cooked silver and
crystal what this meant was that when
Reed Richards basically left to go find
cerebro the device that was used by
Xavier to locate mutants suddenly all
these doom bots start activating
believing that these people are
basically threats that are not supposed
to be here and in the fight it's pretty
straightforward I mean there's not a
whole lot to go on with it but something
that I want you guys to notice here is
they don't make any moves towards Black
Bolt it's like he's not there and the
question is initially asked but the
answer is just kind of left lingering
and so at this point we switch back over
to California to Los Angeles now I
remember Los Angeles is basically the
home of the skull this young kid who
developed the power of mind control and
is working to essentially kind of be the
new red skull so to speak or at least
adopted the insignia of the red skull
and has been essentially consolidating
power now because of the fact that he
has the power of mind-control what this
means is that anyone who just kind of
stumbles across his path any wayward
person who travels to LA for whatever
reason will basically be ensnared inside
a sphere of influence and the result is
that they'll become his pawn but in the
midst of all this Captain America is met
by the arrival of daredevil now remember
this is a person masquerading as
daredevil it's not actually Matt Murdock
we'll find out who this person is but it
is cool because this guy basically shows
up and so he says look I'll join you cap
on your mission I mean you're you're
gonna fail but like I want to be there
to be a part of this whole thing that
you're doing
the whole motivation behind this guy
showing up joining Captain America is
that his audience has been stolen from
him it seems to be the only real
motivation but notice it's kind of
nonsensical and it's kind of silly which
should give you a little bit of insight
into who daredevil is at the moment but
the other half of this is that Captain
America has basically come across a
handful of mutants that exist inside of
Los Angeles and so what he actually ends
up doing is sending these guys directly
over to Cyclops now we'll figure out
with that here in a second but at this
point we jump over to the new sorcerer
supreme clean I remember Clea is
basically the the knee
more or less of dormammu but we're not
really told what goes on with door mama
we're not really told what's going on
with his character or anything like that
what we are told is that at some point
along the line Steven strange is
spiritual essence had like gone out into
you know the the astral plane and
something had happened where it's
believed that his spiritual essence has
been destroyed what this does is it
basically leaves his body without a soul
and the result is that Cleo was the one
who took up the mantle of the new
sorcerer supreme and they're just kind
of hoping Doctor Strange comes back
eventually but the whole idea of Bruce
Banner showing up here with the
Incredible Hulk is to basically say like
they had a dream and the dream was that
they essentially encountered Marvel of
the Creamery Marvel was it was the
original Captain Marvel in Marvel Comics
in Marvel's main continuity he died of
cancer that was a story that was written
by jim Starlin 1984 and he was gone it
was a way to ride him out and basically
try to find a way to replace him with
somebody else
which ultimately became Carol Danvers
but the whole gist of this is that he
essentially appeared a to Bruce Banner
it's kind of like Ian more or less as a
cosmic entity but what Bruce Banner sort
of derived from this was that earth was
was destroyed more or less that you know
when he looked into eon and he saw the
galaxy or the universe inside of eon and
he looked for earth earth wasn't there
anymore because earth had been destroyed
and that's what they're trying to find
out is what happened to the planet Earth
now Bruce Banner views this as kind of a
spiritual message you know like Marvel
reaching out from beyond the grave to
try to warn Bruce Banner of something
and so the whole idea of approaching
clea is to basically say like we're
looking for passage into the realm of
mistress death we want to go to her
realm we want to contact Marvel and we
want to see if he was the one that sent
us this message or if it was just a
crazy dream that I had but it is kind of
cool because in this world of all kinds
of crazy thing flights of fancy Z's you
know and these people with incredible
powers and so on and so forth it makes
sense that like that would be a
legitimate question now at this point we
switch over to what we basically switch
over to Thor this is kind of the funny
thing when it comes to earth ax Earth X
made a lot of predictions about the
future of Marvel Comics in terms of like
different characters we would see in
this story Thor is a woman now Thor was
turned into a chick by Loki that's the
whole basis behind his it was a trick
that was played by Loki on Thor now this
also deals like the storm Giants
basically invading and things are taking
care of pretty quickly by Thor and the
result is of the iron Avengers basically
go out and do something else
it was a huge trick that was played by
Loki to kind of teach Thor humility even
after he was on earth
the idea is that ore can never go back
to Asgard and tell Odin what happened
because if that were to take place then
the spell of Loki would banish Thor from
Midgard for all eternity he would never
be able to come back again and so it's
basically one of those things where like
I'll stay on earth as a chick you know I
basically just be a woman here as
opposed to never being able to come back
but at this point we end up switching
over to to Cyclops and the whole idea of
Cyclops really staying on earth even
though he doesn't need to is largely
done because of the fact that he's
hunting for Jean Grey now initially he's
approached by like his father and he's
approached by what looks like Polaris
and then havoc which is basically like a
family so to speak you know a family of
sorts but they're kind of like hey look
man we can take you off earth it's
essentially this idea that like Cyclops
could leave if he wanted to but he's
looking and trying to see there's a way
for him to get Jean Grey back so we know
jeans not dead but that's kind of like
where his loyalties lie but ultimately
the reason why Jean isn't with him is
because she's with Wolverine in this
story she got with Wolverine and where
we would expect a kind of you know maybe
like a Bonnie and Clyde kind of
situation or scenario where like they're
off having adventures or they live a
really dangerous life instead they have
like the crappiest life imaginable she
just sits at home all day long and like
he just drinks beers all day long and
that's it they just loaf around they're
not actually doing anything with their
lives but it is interesting to see the
stake because for the most part when
people imagine you know Jean Grey going
with Wolverine I get like we said they
usually kind of imagine this this sort
of life were like they're out doing
crazy things we never really imagined
them just kind of settling down in their
lives going nowhere but ultimately what
is up happening is we basically have
this this point whereby we jump back to
the castle of Victor Von Doom and Carnac
hits on a very important thing of course
Karnak is a member of the Inhumans who
actually never went through terrigenesis
at least not in the main Marvel
continuity there's no indication that he
went through it here in this story but
carnage basically very good at like
figuring out the quote-unquote weakness
of things figuring out the problem with
any one particular situation or like a
structure or something along those lines
but his line of logic has led him to one
inevitable conclusion it was not the
implementation of vibranium that led to
like everything going on here instead
the only indication here is that this
involvement of vibranium is a byproduct
of the fact that like it mutated people
like in Wakanda for example it turned
like Panther into like an actual Panther
but like that's about it but that was a
mutation that was going on for like
decades
you know before T'Challa ever can ever
became black panther and
as that was progressing the issue here
is that in a matter of almost overnight
people suddenly develop powers and so in
the mind of Carnac and has nothing to do
with vibranium by radium a have been the
catalyst but it had nothing to do with
vibranium and so that's kind of the
mystery here is if Reed Richards is
wrong if he's basically incorrect about
what it was that gave everybody on earth
powers then the question is what was it
that made this happen but again from
here we jump to a bit of history on the
x-men and that's what's kind of cool
about this is that with each story or I
guess each issue that comes out you get
a little bit of history about things
that were going on in terms what was
going on in the past now there are these
little backup features that are really
more text than actual imagery they kind
of tell you what was going on with
particular characters you know for
example gambits dead Iceman
went into his ice form and couldn't go
back to being into a human form and so
if you were to leave the North Pole he
would essentially melt and so he just
stayed to the North Pole in isolation
all the time I mean just different
things like that you know these these
small little paragraphs that kind of
tell you what's going on with other
characters but the overall idea here is
that when it comes to the x-men one of
the things is kind of hit on here is a
philosophical differences between
Charles Xavier and Magneto now a lot of
this is just kind of par for the course
you know for those of you guys who are
familiar with the characters you kind of
know what they're about but it is kind
of cool because what this does is it
indicates the idea that Magneto's plan
to essentially take down the x-men was a
lot more intricate than the way it is in
the main Marvel Universe and the main
Marvel Universe it's I am the leader of
the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants and I'm
going to implement this plan and the
x-men intervene and the x-men defeat me
my Brotherhood and I retreat and I do it
all over again but the whole idea here
is that it's basically this this notion
that humanity looked at mutant kind
basically and they saw magneto as a
necessary evil in the sense that with
the rise of the x-men these various you
know super-powered beings who were out
there by virtue of an X gene with things
like Scott Summers and Jean Grey having
a blossoming romance because of the idea
that they would you know could
conceivably procreate what it meant was
that with the procreation of mutants
humanity would begin to basically fade
away mutants who begin to replace them
and so because of this humanity looked
at magneto instead we said well maybe
magneto will basically instigate like a
gene war there'll be a war that'll take
place among all the mutants and they'll
basically destroy themselves and things
will be that simple
and it is kind of cool because that was
the plan of magneto in a lot of
different ways the plight of magneto was
sitting down and realizing that Charles
Xavier dream of a peaceful coexistence
was too good for a lot of people to
ignore
and so what magneto did is by playing
the villain he made Charles Xavier into
the good guy and the whole gist of this
is that as the good guy Charles Xavier
has to walk the good guy path and what
that means is the first time he fails
the first time he falters the first
honey makes a mistake
suddenly everybody's on him well he's
not the good guy anymore he's just as
bad as Magneto and if he's just as bad
as bad as magneto then why not just go
join Magneto that was the whole idea was
pretty intelligent and pretty smart the
way the whole thing worked out but again
Reed Richards is kind of visiting what's
left of the Xavier Institute which has
long since been in shambles essentially
grab cerebro for the purpose of going
through and examining everything and
trying to figure out if there's a way
for him to basically locate the inhuman
gene more or less and then allow the in
human family to sort of rise to
prominence again and then all the
Inhumans on earth to leave along with
the royal family that's really kind of
the immediate purpose that he's serving
here but then we switch over to Cyclops
himself and this is cool because what we
end up finding out is the the small band
of mutants that Captain America run into
in Los Angeles were rounded up by
Captain America and sent the Cyclops in
order to be trained but notices Cyclops
is initially adverse to it I mean all
these guys basically attack him all at
the same time and that was just designed
to say hey look here's how far we are in
our training here's how advanced we are
but like Cyclops doesn't really want to
train these guys I mean he does but
basically he doesn't want to fall in
line of being in Charles Xavier because
in his mind it's repeating the same
thing that happened before but like
people are gonna gain power you know
people have Halloway they had before but
training these people on how to use
their powers but basically train them on
how to use their powers so they could
use them nefariously they could walk
away and become villains more dangerous
villains than they were before they met
Cyclops any number of these various
circumstances that could arise but
ultimately he ends up going with it just
because of the fact that it gets him
motivation it gives him purpose notices
for a lot of the older people who were
here Captain America Cyclops these guys
it's doing what they can to latch on to
the last vestiges of what they remember
from like the way things used to be
hoping things go back to the way they
were before clinging to the past unable
to look into the future and so what we
end up doing here is jumping back over
to the whole idea of Bruce Banner and
the Incredible Hulk and all these guys
basically trying to find a way into the
realm of mistress death now one of the
things that's kind of hit on here when
it comes to clear is that mistress death
as she exists here is a lot more evil
than she exists in the main Marvel
Universe and the main moral universe she
toys with people but as one of those
things were like she's willing to barter
there's been times where mistress death
is actually a
outsoles to leave the realm of the dead
if she gets something in return of
significance and miss it doesn't work
that way and this it's once you're in
the realm of the dead you're in there
forever and if you go walking into her
realm and you have a salt she'll take it
and you'll literally just be stuck there
for all eternity you'll never be able to
leave she'll never let you leave so she
seems very vindictive very evil you know
very very cruel and cynical but the
whole idea is that Bruce Banner
basically says son The Incredible Hulk
in there and on the surface it seems
pretty cold-hearted but this is when we
find out that the Incredible Hulk is a
is basically the soul of Bruce Banner
I'm sorry Bruce Banner I guess is the
soul of the whole and so it's basically
this idea that like the Hulk is its own
entity it can thing you can feel
different things like that if it goes
into the realm of mistress death as long
as Bruce banners on the outside then
like there's no risk of stealing the
Hulk's all because the Hulk's soul is on
the outside this in the form of Bruce
Banner and so it's the best way to get
somebody in there to figure out what's
going on the problem with this is the
Incredible Hulk is not the sharpest tool
in the shed
now Banner believes that he's basically
managed to reconcile this information by
essentially like writing to the Hulk and
basically like giving him a message in a
bottle so to speak so that when the
Incredible Hulk is there he can crack
this open he can examine it and
basically take a look at things and just
sort of figure out what's going on but
at this point we switch over to high
club sort of training these x-men to a
degree it's a small moment but again
he's kind of stepping into the role of
Charles Xavier he prefers to be called
mr. s but he's stepping into the role of
Charles Xavier that's basically what he
is now he is a person who has stepped
into the role of a leadership capacity
by circumstance not really by actual
choice but he's maintaining this choice
in neo and in the end has really kind of
the motivation behind it the basis
behind it so it is cool but what we end
up doing is basically following up with
Katherine America and daredevil while
they're essentially racing trying to
stop this mob of people from like
getting to New York basically trying to
control the sphere of influence of the
skull but the way this ends is
essentially them just like going into a
tunnel that's really about it but what
daredevil basically hints at is that he
can be dismembered he can be taken apart
piece by piece and then reassembled
again basically heal himself so again
gives us a little bit of indication who
daredevil is and you know in the earth X
universe but it is cool okay so we are
continuing on with Earth X and again I
god I love this story so much we're
about halfway through right now both
humming in this video will be about a
little over halfway through um this is
such a cool story I love Earth X so much
because it's it's interesting I'm still
debating on whether or not I'm going to
you universe X and paradise X I'm still
not sure yet but what we do in this
video is we initially pick up with the
origin of the Incredible Hulk in Earth X
and for the most part this origin story
is almost identical to the origin that
exists inside Marvel Comics with one
major difference now of course the whole
idea of like Bruce Banner having been a
genius and then going on to basically
develop the gamma bomb that's all still
intact the difference here is that in
Marvel in the main Marvel continuity the
idea was that Bruce Banner had these
different forms of the whole quote
unquote because they represented
different facets of his personality you
had like Joe fix-it who was the mobster
Hulk you had like devil hook different
things like that in Earth X that's not
the case instead they're just evolutions
of the same beam the idea is that inside
of Bruce Banner is this gamma radiation
that's constantly growing and constantly
expanding what the gamma radiation is
trying to do is leave the body of Bruce
Banner and manifest itself physically
and that's what takes place what ends up
happening here is Bruce Banner any
Incredible Hulk basically split and
that's why you have two distinctly
different people here you have Bruce
Banner and then you have the Incredible
Hulk again the caveat to all this is
that Bruce Banner sees through the eyes
of the Incredible Hulk now again this
all ties in to the ongoing events of
what's taking place with regards to
banner and Clea and so on but Before we
jump back into that I do want to kind of
pick up with this next little transition
which deals with Reed Richards looking
for cerebro now again cerebro of course
is the helmet used by Charles Xavier
that was designed for the purpose of
locating mutants but because the x-men
have been defunct for really a number of
years and because Xavier himself is
basically dead what this means is that
the Cerebral helmets just kind of been
out there now under normal circumstances
that helmet can only be used by those
who have telepathic powers Reed Richards
doesn't have those and so the question
is how is he going to be able to pull
this off now what he does is he actually
goes to see Ben Grimm and the reason for
this is because Ben Grimm basically has
within his I guess really within like a
place that Rita built for him these
various schematics of Charles Xavier zhh
brain and Reed Richards is looking for
this because what he can do is basically
quote-unquote modify his own brain to
basically match that of Charles Xavier
and kind of give off this perception
that he has telepathy now this is really
just kind of things going fast and loose
with regards to like Reed Richards
powers let me read read read read read
doesn't really have telepathy but the
idea was that he could basically kind of
trick cerebro into believing
that he does and so we just gotta have
to roll with it we're just gonna have to
roll with it for what it is but before
we find out the conclusion that he comes
to which is a pretty major one what we
end up doing is jumping directly back to
the Incredible Hulk and clear now
remember Clea is the niece of Dormammu
but in Marvel Comics she was basically
the apprentice and really the lover of
Doctor Strange for quite some time the
difference here is that in the earth X
line of comics dr. Strange's spiritual
essence is basically dead and his body's
just there or at least its belief his
spiritual essence is dead and his body's
just kind of sitting there at the same
time Bruce Banner had a dream that came
from Captain Marvel that the world was
going to end and so that's why they're
traveling into the realm of mistress
death again if you want to know that
know more about that in a little more
detail the last video of flesh all that
stuff out but they're basically going
into the realm of mistress death to find
Marvel and asked him the question why
did you appear to me in a dream and why
are you telling me the world is ending
and so once the Incredible Hulk goes
into the realm of mistress death as a
tether of sorts what this means is it
allows us to basically see what goes on
inside this world and this is kind of
ironic because in the land of the dead
the heroes who were there don't know
they're dead instead they're still
continuing on to fight like they always
did now notice this it's not a common
book fight the way we would expect it
which is to say like the x-men fighting
an x-men villain and the Fantastic Four
fighting a Fantastic Four villain or at
least what's left of the Fantastic Four
is just heroes fighting bad guys and so
they're just kind of caught and this
eternal struggle of good guys versus bad
guys and this is what they do but
because of the fact of the heroes don't
know they're dead they're just
continuing on the same way they always
did and it's kind of cool to see these
small little things here and there you
know for example a Susan storm and
Johnny Storm are looking for Reed
Richards and Ben Grimm because they
don't know they're dead now ultimately
we end up having the Incredible Hulk in
his search for Marvel who basically
travels to the realm of Doctor Strange
and this kind of Land of the Dead
version of New York and then comes
across the spirit the essence of Doctor
Strange which is passed on to the dead
and Doctor Strange so he just says hey
look there's a lot going on here that
you don't know about I don't have time
to tell you everything but the person
that you see is Loki the individual that
you would call Loki is not as devious as
you believe he is instead like he's
going to be one of the people who's
supposed to help things the problem with
this is he's allied himself with someone
evil thought before the Incredible Hulk
can find out what it is we basically end
up just sort of transitioning back to
Bruce Banner and this is when we start
to go through everything that's going on
because what ends up taking place is
Bruce Banner really kind of calls out
and
look things are getting kind of hairy in
here ultimately like Thor jumps in now
it's really Bruce Banner putting on a
Rouge Rhonda me Doctor Strange tells the
Incredible Hulk
really tells Banner through the eyes of
the Hulk do not tell anyone that you're
talking to me right now no one can know
you're talking to me and the reason for
this is because the death of dr. strange
came at the hands of Clea she killed her
own master she basically destroyed his
spiritual essence and the reason for
this is because she turned her back on
Doctor Strange and allied herself with
Loki so like it's pretty intense and
pretty hardcore and it is pretty
interesting but what we are not doing at
this point is jumping directly to
Captain America because again inside the
city of Los Angeles you basically had a
young kid called the skull and this kid
essentially had the power to dominate
the minds of others cast illusions
different things like that
basically bend them to his whim and the
result is that he's been massive in
amassing an army that's about 10,000
strong and where Captain America had
sent out these few mutants that he
discovered here and there to basically
go receive training from from Cyclops
they've been banding together in Captain
America's basically been building an
army under the auspices that when you
end up having the scroll and his forces
who show up in New York
Dadda Captain America is gonna be able
to take them on with his own gathering
of sorts now one thing to bear in mind
here it's not like the skull is showing
up to New York with an army of like
10,000 super-powered people it's not
really like that I said it's just an
army of 10,000 people and so there are a
lot of super-powered beings there but
just because people have powers doesn't
mean they have even powers so really the
scales could kind of go either way
the benefit for the skull is that at the
end of the day the good guys will try
not to hurt innocent people and that's
where the villains will ultimately end
up coming out on top and the various
skirmishes and the conflicts that we've
seen over the course of Marvel Comics
history now at this point we jump
directly to the origin of Peter Parker
spider-man and again this origin falls
very much in line in the same way it
starts to give us this origin of Peter
Parker who gained his powers from a
radioactive spider bite ultimately he
fell in love with with with Gwen Stacy
Uncle Ben died Peter Parker had his
whole history when Stacy eventually died
in the night Gwen Stacy died storyline
and then of course he goes on to marry
Mary Jane Watson now basically of course
their whole situation comes to an end
but it also hits on things like Peter
Parker getting the Venom symbiote during
the original Secret Wars from 1984 and
that explains how the venom simian is
here on earth so again all these
histories are still pretty much the
exact same the difference is that in
this story we end up basically picking
up with John Jameson showing up to the
two people who have been analyzing this
the entire time
now that's why I wanted to kind of hold
off and basically offer this explanation
on who these guys are what we have here
is essentially who watch you The Watcher
and machine man
now Machine Man made his debut back in
1977 with 2001 a Space Odyssey issue
number 8 and that was actually a line of
comics if I remember correctly and godom
that's one of those like really obscure
line of comics that's one of those
concepts that I believe was like thought
up and it was written and drawn by Jack
Kirby it was like his own solo thing
outside of like the influence of Stan
Lee or anybody else but when it comes to
like Aaron's stack he is the son of a
guy named dr. Abel stack and an issue
number a what we found out was that
there were a group of scientists who are
basically trying to create super
soldiers of source but they were
creating robots that would become
soldiers and the journal gist of this
was that they would in turn basically be
sent out through all through all of
humanity and nobody would know they
existed because nobody would be able to
tell the difference between them and
regular people so think like terminators
more or less the issue with this was
that about 50 I've a rule there were 51
that were commissioned and the other 50
were destroyed yes x1 through 50 were
completely annihilated by the by the
scientists themselves due to the fact
that the robots began to display traits
that indicated that they were
essentially going insane now the reason
why aaron stock didn't go crazy is
because abel stack actually took him
home and then treated him like a person
raised him like a human being and by
virtue of receiving this sort of
extrasensory input on being perceived as
a human aaron stock began to perceive
himself as a human and so is basically
just taking in all the sensory
information and then assimilating it
into his own programming and that's the
difference between Abel stack and the
other or the other x50 robots is the
other extra - robots didn't have human
stimulus and so when they were basically
assigned the programming task of your
job is to protect humanity they wouldn't
really know how to function accordingly
they would just eventually start to go
insane because their programming
couldn't account for the orders they
were given with how they reconcile those
orders and so I where he's really one of
the more obscure characters in Marvel
Comics what ended up happening in this
story is Aaron stack was basically
whisked away to the moon by watching The
Watcher and who ought to basically went
to Aaron and said you are going to
become the new watcher and I'm going to
teach you how to be a watcher by showing
you everything that's going on on earth
and you're going to look into the past
of everything and you're going to
compare it to what's going on now and
you're spent you're basically going to
learn to understand humanity you're
gonna understand Humanity on a much
greater scale than you current
and so that's what's been happening the
two of them have basically been looking
at everything that's been going on and
we've essentially been getting like the
history of the Marvel Universe in Earth
X by virtue of these two now the other
half of this is that as Aaron stack had
been watching everything that was going
on and learning all this information
he'd been simultaneously downloading all
these backlogs and all these catalogs
essentially everything who watches The
Watcher had stored even though hoo-wah -
didn't really tell him - so from a lot
to his mindset he was talking to a robot
that had an understanding of humanity
but didn't really have a personality per
se he was basically a blank slate but
Aaron stack is not a blank slate he had
curiosity he has anger he has rage he
has love and you know jealousy and
affection and different things like that
and so the result is that he's basically
learned that who watched The Watcher is
harboring a secret that there's
something going on here behind the
scenes that who watch who knows about
that Aaron's tak himself intends to try
to end so it's almost like all these
different roads are sort of converging
into the same place now in the midst of
all this of course John Jameson shows up
and says look there's a massive ship
headed this way and like it looks like
it's powerful enough to obliterate the
earth I have no idea what this means or
what it's going to do but before we end
up jumping into all that we basically go
back to what it is that's taking place
on earth and we essentially pick up with
the forces of the skull showing up in
New York and basically attacking
everybody that they come across now this
is really more of like a hey we're here
we're conquering everything those who
disagree will be dealt with they'll be
you know either they'll be brought under
my control or they'll be destroyed and
then what has kind of expand our sphere
of influence and where Captain America
shows up to the residence of Tony Stark
the argument he makes here is really
really intriguing the idea of him
showing up is saying hey look man like
you're part of this just like anybody
else you have to get involved but
remember Tony Stark is kind of removed
he's isolated from humanity he just kind
of serves the purpose of trying to keep
things in order as well as trying to
make sure that like the global the
global supplies are kept in check and
everything else just kind of exists out
there
and so really everything outside of
whatever it is that Norman Osborn cares
about and whatever it is Tony Stark
cares about it's just kind of no-man's
land it's just kind of like you know the
land of do as you please maybe you'll
survive maybe you won't but that's not
my problem now again we're the forces of
New York stemming off this attack as
best they can the school's ability to
like dominate the minds of others is
seen in a multitude of ways for example
the cops that are with
with you know sergeant Luke Cage are
forced to turn on Luke Cage but of
course you know cage has unbreakable
skin and so the bullets they used to try
to shoot him with don't really work mate
a Parker the daughter of Peter Parker
who jumps into the Frank
now here's kind of a funny thing here
maybe Parker again is currently in
possession of the venom simian we talked
about that when it came to the whole
thing that's constant what Peter Parker
says is like you had the Venom symbiote
you have to learn how to control
yourself but ultimately she's kind of
young and headstrong and jumping into it
all now we will find out there's a
little more than what's going on here
but it is cool to kind of see this thing
take place Peter Parker trying to impart
his pearls of wisdom onto his daughter
at the same time we have our Reed
Richards who's again get hidden to
analyze everything that's going on and
Reed Richards begins to come to the
conclusion or he begins to look around
after modifying the helmet of Charles
Xavier and comes to the realization
these guys the people who are walking
around earth they're not mutants they're
Inhumans now again this story was
written long before the events of the of
uh of infinity and Marvel Comics so this
like predates the modern day idea of the
inhuman Terrigen mists spreading
throughout the world now how that
happened is the question the question is
that if all these people are inhuman now
and if all these people derive their
powers from the Terrigen mists then who
was it that spread the mists throughout
the world and that's when we start to
realize the idea that like crystal for
example is starting to develop her
inhuman powers that these various people
who are who are here are are manifesting
their abilities and who knows what form
they're going to take but the question
this ass is was it Maximus the mad who
set this off you know basically the the
insane brother of Black Bolt and the
initial response of Medusa is that's not
possible one his bomb was destroyed and
to Maximus the mad is dead and so
there's no reason to believe that he's
the one responsible for all this and so
at this point we jump back to Bruce
Banner to the Incredible Hulk and this
is cool because once we get into this
situation initially it's clear and Loki
who are kind of like cool today's one
we're finished here like everything is
fine and then suddenly they're met with
your return to the Incredible Hulk
alongside Thor who have really just kind
of brought themselves back out of the
realm of mistress death by quite
literally pulling on the the rope that
they used to enter in the first place
kind of that tether that was offered
there but we're clear is overpowered by
the forces of like for and The
Incredible Hulk she starts calling out
for Loki who basically bailed and that's
the crazy thing about this Loki is never
a reliable or trustworthy character in
Marvel Comics he never has been and he
never will be there's been times where
he's tried to do good things but by an
with the exception of the most recent
run by Jason Aaron Loki has always been
a deceptive character he's always been
the master of trickster in lies and so
it's cool because basically Clea got
what everybody knew she was going to get
which was left hanging and so where she
basically says look if this is how
things are gonna be then fine I'll just
destroy it all I'll literally obliterate
the earth I'll leave and go do whatever
Thor turns around and beat you to death
with a hammer and that's the end of Clea
and so from here we pick up with Captain
America where he actually transitions to
Russia and it's kind of interesting
because when he's there we find out this
is where Colossus went to after the the
fall of the x-men the death of Charles
Xavier when whoever was left as part of
the x-men team disbanded that he
returned back to Russia went back home
and he's been one of the many people
who's been fighting on this front of
making sure that like all the resources
that are available are gathered as they
need to be and they're basically sent
across the world to the places that need
them so they're kind of like this
massive resource for food and supplies
the issue is that when Captain America
shows up he says look the skull is a kid
the skull of hockey in New York is a kid
I'm mustering as many forces as I can
see I can conceivably do in order to try
to bring as many people under my belt as
I possibly can and where Colossus says
no Captain America again reiterate he
says look this is a kid and he looks at
the world through a kid's perspective he
doesn't see all the ends he sees the
world in black and white he doesn't see
all the shades of grey it's kind of a
wild scenario in the middle of all this
the group suddenly attacked by like Nick
Fury and what we find out is that Nick
Fury's life model decoys have been
routinely showing up an attacking Peter
they've been been consistently showing
up and like trying to take these guys
out because their program is basically
just starting to go awry it's really
it's really cool and it's really
fascinating to show like these other
parts of the world but again put you
back up with Mayday where she goes and
basically fights Iron Maiden who's you
know kind of being controlled by by Red
Skull or I'm sorry aya by school at
least it seems like it is ultimately
she's able to get the upper hand and
actually able to get to defeat she's
actually able to defeat the Iron Maiden
and call it a day just by kind of you
know covering her face and webbing and
essentially cutting off her oxygen
supply and knocking her out accordingly
but once she shows up and goes to
confront the skull
she learns the lesson that all
inexperienced superheroes do just
because you can fight a battle doesn't
mean you should fight a battle when
Mayday shows up and she lands in front
of the skull with the intention of
taking him out she can't move she can't
do anything and the skull says actually
you're in
with me and just dominates her and
that's where people begin to just kind
of give up and call it a day it's really
like everything's basically lost here
and so the skull shows up to that to the
to the brilliant residence of president
Norman Osborn and simply says like your
reign is over we're gonna throw you out
that window you're gonna die and I'm
gonna become the new President of the
United States okay so I learned like I
learned a gaming term apparently it's
called like being tilted which basically
means like you're mad because you're
because you're losing if that's the case
I used to make people tilt in Call of
Duty all the time back in the day I was
like man don't be mad at me for wrecking
you be mad at yourself for being so bad
but anyway uh so we are continuing on
with our story on Earth X yes I love
Earth X is one of my favorite stories I
love this story again this is like a
dystopian future so it's just like man
like like things are really popping off
now so far what we basically had is the
idea that like everybody on earth has
powers I mean we didn't know exactly how
it was they all got powers but like
everybody on earth has powers ah the
result is that there really is no more
need for superheroes but things turned
out exactly like we would expect the
world's completely gone to pot not only
that in Los Angeles California you had
the skull which is basically just a kid
then had the ability to like dominate
the minds of others but the result is
that because the skulls army is
basically growing a number to the tens
of thousands and he's making his way
across the country basically looking to
completely and totally take over the
United States and then the world Captain
America has basically been traveling
around trying to rally as many people to
his side as he can now of course from
here we pick up an England with Captain
Britain this is kind of cool
because Captain Britain as he's shown
here it's basically just the guy who's
running Britain at this point in time we
just got the guy who's basically running
the show we're not really told exactly
how this happened but like we can
surmise we can kind of take a guess and
most likely what happened was that like
America in England when all these
different people across the country gain
their powers the government basically
just fell to pieces and Captain Britain
rose up now the funny thing about this
is that when it comes to Brian Braddock
he's one of those characters that people
just sort of make fun of right like oh
man Captain Britain he's gonna save the
day not that's kind of how people that's
kind of how people you know talk about
Captain Britain he's kind of a joke
about laughable character that no one
really pays much attention to but if you
go back and read his stories while he is
kind of a joke of a character the way
he's written sometimes he's God at work
counts but the whole idea is that with
Captain America showing up here and
saying look like we need you to our side
what we find
is that what basically passes for
Excalibur in earth attacks that they're
all basically gone like they're they're
basically out of this now what ended up
taking place here is the group won
against a guy named grey gargoyle who I
want to say is Paul Duval
I think that's his name I want to say
with his powers he can touch things and
turn them to stone I can't remember
honestly you slept so obscure of a
character and I'm too lazy to look him
up but regardless all the members of
Excalibur are stuck in stone but
basically that's why Captain Britain's
like the only person here Captain
Britain says no I'm not gonna join your
ranks like go do your own thing but I'm
my loyalty is to Britain my loyalty is
not to United States I will do whatever
I need to do in order to keep this place
protected and so from here we pick up
with the skull in New York in the home
of Norman Osborn now the funny thing
about this is that this throws them to
sharp relief the nature of the President
of the United States right like take
away the armies take away the Secret
Service what's the president of United
States just a guy in an office and
that's it like the President exists and
functions because people are willing to
do what he asks them to do but that's it
I mean Norman Osborn is just like a guy
who's here but like when there's no one
there to protect him well then suddenly
the president becomes awfully vulnerable
and that's what goes on here like the
skull walks in and it's just like Judas
a guy in an office man like you have no
power like you you are just a person
who's here and like all the people who
could help you I've taken control of and
like they all belong to me so like
you're gonna die now like we're gonna
kill you and that's what happens here
like he essentially turns the mind of
Norman Osborn inside out and forces
Norman Osborn to like confront gwen
stacy now again this ties in to the
whole history of spider-man and the fact
that the main Marvel Universe continuity
of spider-man is still a part of Earth X
in a sense that Peter Parker was in a
relationship with Gwen Stacy she died at
the hands of Norman Osborn and he's just
kind of forced to face this illusion of
her being it but of course the mask is
basically ripped off but of course again
in this scenario is actually the skull
himself who looks like Gwen Stacy but
the mask of Norman Osborn is torn off
and that's when we find out it's Ben
Green Goblin the entire time so again
it's kind of what we expected for the
most part I mean Norman Osborn a Green
Goblin go hand in hand and and there's
there's rarely ever been a circumstance
where Marvel has given us Norman Osborn
and then not brought in Green Goblin
somewhere along the line but at this
point we pick up with really with
Machine Man
meeting with Reed Richards now again in
the last video we talked about how
Machine Man was created for the purpose
of being a super soldier more or less
but he had essentially developed human
attributes and the result was that
somewhere along
I'm the watcher had basically snatched
him off of Earth and brought him to the
moon now the idea was that the watcher
is blinded we don't know who blinded the
watcher we just know the watchers blonde
and the result is that Machine Man
started you know spill or at least start
smelling all this information to Reed
Richards all the things that he's
learned and one of the things that he's
learned here is that when it comes to
like all these beings on earth who have
superpowers that were basically
antibodies or at least these these
superheroes and all these people with
powers are essentially antibodies for
the earth they're designed to fight off
quote-unquote infection that infection
basically being whatever space invading
organism or race or Thanos or
what-have-you comes to earth and tries
to destroy it they're basically designed
to be a safeguard but we don't know why
all we know is like that's the case the
implication is that it's because the
Celestials wanted it to be that way but
again we don't know if everybody having
powers was part of the plan or if
everybody having powers was the plan
gone awry so again it is kind of
intriguing but it's designed to kind of
build up this whole idea of like the
greater role that Earth X plays with
regards to this story but at this point
we pick back up with the Inhumans and
again the Inhumans are not really our
guides on this really our guide is more
of a machine man but the Inhumans are
here to provide us with a kind of
objective perspective which is to say
they basically shown up they've come
back to earth after everybody has powers
and they're basically figuring things
out as we figure things out is the
reader which is one of the reasons why I
like the Inhumans as they exist in this
story the issue with this is that Carnac
who doesn't really have any powers per
se specializes and like figuring out how
things work basically it's kind of a
caveat that Marvel uses to give them
powers even though it doesn't really
have powers there's just bit thing that
he can do but Karnak is been trying to
figure out what's been going on here in
terms of why everybody has powers the
initial indication was that everybody
getting powers everybody being in a
human was the result of the actions of
Maximus the Mac the brother of Black
Bolt who had somehow detonated this
terrigen bomb and gave everybody inhuman
powers on earth the indication was that
it wasn't actually Maximus who did it
because Maximus was defeated by Black
Bolt before it could be done so the
question was asked like who who set this
whole terrigenesis thing in motion
and so what Carnac starts to sort of
question Medusa to a degree basically
say hey look maybe it wasn't really
Maximus the mad maybe it was you know
somebody that guy over there who doesn't
talk maybe it was him you know were he
kind of hints at that idea
Medusa dismisses it now remember Medusa
as the wife of Black Bolt is loyal to
her husband and loyal to the king Medusa
will kill every inhuman
that exists out there before she will
betray her husband willingly and that
leads us into the revelation of who
detonated the Terrigen bomb and we end
up finding out it was actually
blackboard himself that black vault had
detonated this terrigen bomb and gave
everybody on earth and human powers and
the reason for this is because of the
fact in the mind of Black Bolt that
there were some Inhumans who had left
the royal family and there were some
Inhumans who by whatever manner and
whatever means had developed their
powers and the result was that black
balled saw how they were treated in a
lot of ways people believe they were
mutants because no one knew about the
Inhumans and so on Black Bolt looked and
realized that some of them are actually
Inhumans and that normal human beings
are treating them terribly because they
have fantastic powers black bolts idea
was that if the Inhumans are going to
leave earth he's going to provide
quote-unquote one last gift he's going
to detonate this terrigen bomb and all
the Inhumans that exist on earth are
going to gain powers and that's exactly
what happened everybody basically
started gaining powers and that's what
ends up happening with with regards to
machine man explaining all these things
to Reed Richards when we jump back
machine man basically says like this was
part of the plan when the Celestials
modify the genes of early man and they
created the deviants and the Eternals
and the baseline humans would eventually
go on to develop mutant powers or what
have you and went being humans arrived
on earth and so on and so forth all that
was part of the role of these Celestials
that this is what the Celestials do the
Celestials travel from one world to the
next and they plant their their
offspring their seed so to speak inside
of a planet and then they charge the
denizens of that planet to keep it safe
not really telling them what it is
instead they just modify their genes so
that there are various superheroes that
exist they'll fight among amongst one
another
but they will be protective of their
home and so following the desire for
survival if an alien race shows up like
vanos invades or something like that
they'll fight off Thanos because he's a
villain he wants to destroy the earth
they want to keep the earth safe all the
while not realizing what they're
actually doing it's protecting this
celestial seed inside of the earth and
that's what's happening right now at
this point what seems to be going on is
a Celestials are making their return
because the seed has germinated and now
it's just a matter of the celestial
inside the earth being born and what it
does when that happens the entirety of
the earth will be destroyed and so at
this point we jump directly to the
Battle of New York basically with the
skulls army facing off against Captain
America's forces and this is interesting
this is one of the one of the reasons
why the skull is such an intriguing
character because this guy is basically
just a kid and he views the world as a
well I want respect treat me with
respect if you don't treat me with
respect then I'm just gonna be angry at
you like he's very much childlike in
terms of how we've used the world and
the result is that we're one of the one
of his members basically insults him uh
then he presumably says you guys do what
I tell you to you guys don't have
freedom here you guys do whatever it is
that I tell you to do you guys live and
breathe because I allow you to and he
illustrates this point by taking away
everybody's ability to move and so you
have Captain America's forces running
through just killing every single person
that they come across do destroying all
these different forces of the skull and
then ultimately going for the skull
himself now ultimately we end up finding
out that like the forces of Captain
Britain ended up joining the forces of
Captain America and they're literally
just going through and wrecking as many
people as they can
now ultimately the skull simply says
okay fine everybody get back to it
because honestly what keenum Oh am I
gonna have if I can't dominate this
place at the same time what you also
have is the Incredible Hulk in this
situation I remember this fight being as
cool as it is brings in some pretty
unique things The Incredible Hulk is an
extension of Bruce Banner not very much
in a literal sense Bruce Banner is
basically the soul of be Incredible Hulk
and so in this instance the skull can't
really dominate the incredible Hulk's
mind because there's not really a mind
there to dominate the Hulk does what
Bruce Banner wants it to because it's
like Bruce Banner tearing off an arm and
the arm doing whatever it is the Bruce
Banner wants us to do that's how this
works and so because of this where the
skull tries to dominate the Hulk right
off the bat it ultimately doesn't work
but what is up happening is the forces
of the skull managed to get a hold of
Bruce Banner and when they do they
basically control the Incredible Hulk as
long as he dominates Banner he dominates
the Hulk and so what's basically
happening is the 4tl really the skull
himself is just slowly and steadily
taking over all the forces of Captain
America the school continues to sort of
torment Captain America again like
making him see all these things making
him do all these things the things that
he doesn't want to do ending the war so
on and so forth it is kind of intriguing
and so that's when we find out that
again because of the fact that Black
Bolt had detonated the chair Jim bomb
what he had also done is he tried wanted
to cover his tracks leaving earth and
basically say like we've done into this
bomb no one can know what we've done
we've timed the detonation of this bond
so that when Reed Richards activates his
device that he will believe that he
basically set all this in motion that
somehow energy from vibranium in order
to give the world you know infinite
energy that somehow it gave everybody
powers we can just kind of walk away and
let them believe that
The Watcher would have seen everything
that had happened and The Watcher would
have known everything that had happened
and The Watcher would have told Reid
Richard he would have told the earth
superheroes and so the result was that
Black Bolt had taken the eyes of the
watcher he basically blinded him so
again this if you guys look at this
story for what it is for these little
moments here and there there are a lot
of stories it's spun out of Marvel
Comics that we learned about this whole
thing for example the idea of a Terrigen
bomb being detonated and everybody
getting powers from from terrigenesis on
earth that was used in the events of the
aftermath of infinity and though the
whole idea of inhuman The Watcher being
blinded that's original sent all these
stories that Marvel has recently
launched have all been predicated on
this there are a lot of cool things that
go on here but what we end up finding
out is that the idea of Black Bolt is to
try to destroy the Celestials now the
voice he has is capable of doing it the
voice can like shatter a gun this is one
of those things where Marvel kind of
beefs up the power of Black Bolt for the
purpose of this story in the main Marvel
Universe black bolts nowhere near this
powerful but if you read house of him
it's definitely powerful enough he
whispers and wipes out what amounts to
like two or three football fields worth
of land I mean it's a crazy set of
events Black Bolt flies out to meet the
Celestials on the blue area of the moon
in an effort to try to destroy them and
hopefully find some way to be able to
save the earth okay so getting back into
our discussions on Earth X I'm really
excited about this because this is when
we start to wind things down for the
most part where we have like maybe one
more video left after this and that's
pretty much when we conclude it but this
is cool because this this actually has a
pretty huge moment at the end of the
story the cool thing is again we're
basically talking about a story where
everybody on earth gain superpowers
you know it's essentially a story where
black bolt of the Inhumans had detonated
the Terrigen bomb and effectively set
the Terrigen mists all around the earth
waking up all these different powers of
terrigenesis inside of people and the
result is that the where we would
normally believe that like the earth
might become a better place what this
basically gave us was the idea that the
earth became somewhat of a worse place
because you had people who were like
well now I've got superpowers I can do
anything and this really hit at home
with the idea of the skull basically
this young kid whose power was to
dominate the minds of others now of
course Captain America hadn't become
somewhat disillusioned as well as Peter
Parker who abandon Israel to spider-man
them alongside whatever superheroes are
left that haven't been dominated by the
skull are basically trying to like keep
New York from completely going under and
that's one thing to bear in mind the
skull was based out of LA
and so over the course of however long
he had basically transitioned from Los
Angeles moved all the way east to New
York this is a pretty big moment because
what this means is that essentially
anybody with superpowers that the skull
came across was brought under his
control and when he moved into the city
of New York basically he's got an army
of millions of people at his disposal
the guy dominates the entirety of New
York he's got everybody he picked up
from LA which is already in the millions
moving all the way to the east so I mean
it's a huge number at this point and in
truth we're talking about Captain
America for the most part fighting a
losing battle but the cool thing about
this is that when Peter Parker shows
back up again and when he starts to talk
about how these guys are basically
mindless slaves of the skull suddenly it
triggers something in the mind of
Captain America sudden we hadn't thought
about before and what we end up doing is
transitioning to the residents of of Ben
Grimm the thing and Alicia masters and
this is cool because remember Alicia's
powers basically is the ability to give
life to clay to essentially mold
something out of clay and then bring it
to life so that it can either you know
operate of its own accord or it can do
whatever she tells it to do but Before
we jump into all this what we end up
doing is picking back up with really
like like the Celestials themselves at
the end of the last video we had talked
about how Black Bolt of the Inhumans had
basically left earth and take it off to
the moon to confront the Celestials for
when they arrived and try to find a way
to destroy them but what we're basically
told here in this conversation between
who watch you the watcher in Reed
Richards is that in truth the actions of
Black Bolt are are null I mean there's
there's nothing he can do to stop the
Celestials he's just not that powerful
he doesn't have the capabilities to do
it but recounted and says that was never
the point the point of Black Bolt was
never to like destroy the Celestials the
point of Black Bolt was to let out a
quasi sonic scream that would basically
be an SOS and it would call for help it
would basically send out a signal to you
know one or more people more beings out
there that would bring them in and
essentially allow them to fight on
behalf of Earth's superheroes to stop
the celestial host and so what we end up
doing is jumping back to Captain America
and this is where we find out the entire
plan that he had the goal was that if
those individuals who can think for
themselves are basically taken under the
control of the skull then basically you
know essentially make an army of people
that the skull can't control and that's
where the whole scheme comes in Captain
America's idea here is to create an
entire army of clay figures who can
fight against the skull and his arm
and the skull can't control them but
this is cool because what ends up
happening is Captain America shows up as
a clay model only for us to realize it's
not actually a clay model it's Captain
America covered in clay the idea was to
get close enough to the sculpt that he
would never suspect him that he was just
think it's one of the soldiers who were
out there but when Captain America runs
up on the sculpt he does the only thing
he can do and he kills him now that's
huge this is a huge moment with Captain
America Captain America under normal
circumstances will never kill an enemy
it's kind of a rule of his character as
far as I'm aware and Marvel Comics I
don't think he's ever actually killed
people before I mean I'm sure there's
times where like he would have to but I
mean for the most part like no enemy is
beyond redemption he's very much a
Batman esque in that regard in terms of
how he views enemies and how he views
your foes and different things like that
but in this instance in this story this
is designed to be a Captain America
starkly different from the one that
we're used to a Captain America that is
kind of beyond the role of saying like
everyone can be saved and looking at
like the harsh reality of the war of the
world he's in and saying sometimes
there's only one alternative and that is
to kill the scope it's the only option
they had and so with the skull being
killed everybody's basically released
from his mind control and then
essentially we end up finding out that
like a Tony Stark where he's been
residing in this Citadel of sorts that
he's basically aware of what's going on
with the Celestials now these celestial
beings essentially are the reason why
everybody has powers or at least why
some people have powers and that Black
Bolt was essentially kind of like trying
to complete this circle without really
realizing what was going on and the
reason why I say this is because black
hole of the Inhumans was aware of the
Celestials he was aware of the idea that
the various superheroes on earth didn't
just get powers one day that their genes
had been modified by the Celestials so
that they would gain powers
somewhere along the line and that they
would basically be antibodies to protect
the celestial seed inside of the earth
so that when does he matures and when
the seed is ready to basically emerge
from earth that yes it would destroy the
entirety of the planet Earth but a new
celestial would be born Black Bolt knew
about all this and Black Bolt had given
everybody on earth powers by the you
know by way of terrigenesis because he
knew that the Celestials would
eventually return one day and when they
do that would have to be superheroes who
would be capable of taking down the
Celestials the problem is that no one
has the power to be able to do this
because remember when it comes to
terrigenesis it's a crapshoot there's no
way to know what powers you're gonna
have there's no way to know what your
powers are going to be
you go into care Genesis and you emerge
with whatever abilities you have but
this random chance the probability of
somebody developing powers that you know
can basically challenge the Celestials
increases exponentially the more people
there are with powers on earth and so at
the same time Tony Stark had realized
exactly what was going on as well and
what Tony had been doing the entire time
he'd been hiding out in his bunker is
basically developing a massive
god-killer kind of armor now again this
is one of the reasons why Earth X is
such an influential story because you
look at things like this and then
suddenly you jump forward to the more
recent run of Iron Man when when you
know they're introduced to like the
god-killer armor which is basically a
giant suit that was designed to destroy
Celestials and so again that's why this
really influenced a lot of future
stories but it's funny because even Tony
Stark himself realizes that he's a
stopgap measure he doesn't have the
power to like destroys Celestials he
doesn't have that kind of ability
because the Celestials are godly beings
they're entities they're designed to be
beyond any real human that exists out
there the other half of this is that
picking up with like the Asgardians
themselves the funny thing is that Loki
is the only person who realized the
nature of things now remember we
discovered this earlier in the story who
walked through The Watcher he basically
explained this to us earlier in the
story that the Asgardians aren't beings
who are literally gods they were
formless they were just some sort of you
know some entities that existed out
there and they were given form when they
first met humans that humans looked upon
them and said Wow
these beings must be the ass Guardians
like if this must be Odin this must be
Loki this must be Thor and then suddenly
these beings adopted that mentality and
they became the very heroes of the very
characters that humans believed in and
so literally the Asgardians are funneled
by human belief that's the whole basis
behind Ragnarok the Ragnarok won't
happen because like Loki will lead an
army against Asgard Ragnarok will happen
and Asgard will end because eventually
humanity will be destroyed and when
humanity is destroyed there'll be no one
left to believe in the Asgardians ergo
these beings will revert back to their
shapeless forms quote unquote Asgard
will come to an end but Loki is the only
one to have realized this Odin for all
these people none of them believed him
they all think it's just the ravings of
a madman that is insanity
and so Loki does the only thing he can
do and basically kills himself and in
Reverse to the realm of mistress death
now we're gonna find out there's
actually a motivation for why he did
this but it is cool because again as
people who kind of look at him and say
well he's a trickster you know he's a
guy
why is all he is and he's just making
things up it's just absolute nonsense
but jumping back over to to iron man you
know in this kind of last-ditch effort
to take down these Celestials to buy as
much time as possible he literally just
like flies his vessel into one of them
and is totally destroyed but what is up
happening is we basically find out that
like the efforts of Reed Richards and
really the efforts of Black Bolt rang
out true that where black bolts voice
was sent out into the cosmos in an
effort to find help that we switch over
to like Jameson basically the son of Jay
jonah Jameson a person is working on the
moon at the moment that he's essentially
gained access to the ultimate nullifier
and where he intends to use the ultimate
nullifier to destroy all things there's
no need for him to and the reason why
there is no need for him toobe is
because the backup the signal sent out
by Black Bolt has been received the
being that they were hoping for who
would show up to basically save earth
has arrived what this means is that
Galactus has finally returned back to
earth okay so we are finally picking
back up with the events of Earth X and
we we basically wrap it up we are
finished with Earth X at the end of this
video and it's been one heck of a ride I
mean honestly this was just a philan
story until we could get close enough to
continue our videos on like Thanos and
you know the events leading it's like
Infinity Gauntlet and so on and so forth
I'm still on the fence about whether or
not I'm gonna do universe X and paradise
X but with earth X we basically pick up
following the arrival of Galactus and
this was the huge revelation that it
basically come out of the events of
Earth X that all the superheroes that
existed on earth the entire history of
the earth that it was all basically
preordained or at least as close to
preordained as you can get that the
Celestials essentially travel around
from planet to planet they plant their
seed inside of a planet so that it can
give birth to a new celestial and in
order to make sure that the planet stays
safe his Celestials in turn modify the
genes of whatever citizens or whatever
you know species is the dominant species
on that planet so that they will develop
superpowers and the idea is that like
any species trying to maintain itself
trying to ensure its own survival
they'll face off against any external
threat that would try to destroy the
world
all the while never realizing that
they're actually protecting a celestial
seed what this means is that when the
celestial seed is born the earth will be
destroyed now something that I want you
guys to notice here is that Galactus
begins the process of constructing his
world of our Industrials attempt to try
to stop
lactis it's really more of like putting
up forcefields things like that but the
Celestials don't actually try to kill
Galactus at least they don't initially
and the reason for this is remember it's
all about balance in Earth X Galactus
basically travels around the cosmos and
consumes life-sustaining planets or
planets capable of supporting life
because that's where the Celestials will
plant their seeds and it's just designed
to basically keep a celestial population
from running out of control from
basically dominating the entirety of an
individual universe and so because of
the fact that Galactus is going through
and essentially destroying the celestial
seed inside of the planet the Celestials
in turn begin to start to launch an
attack against Galactus now there are a
couple of things that I want you guys to
also notice too for example you've got
the Silver Surfer but you also have you
also have shallow ball now shallow ball
of course is basically the girlfriend of
Norrin Radd before he became the Silver
Surfer and he had essentially sacrificed
his life and became a silver surfer in
order to spares in law his home planet
but again Earth X feeds into the nature
of Galactus and the Celestials and so
what this man is Galactus didn't just
show up to zenn-la one day for the
purpose of just consuming it because he
was just really really hungry one day it
was basically the whole idea that he
showed up here because there was a
celestial seed inside Zin law and so
where the Silver Surfer said find spare
my planet I will become your new Herald
the result is that that's exactly what
happened now of course Chalobah ended up
becoming an equivalent to Silver Surfer
and we're not really told exactly how
that happens in this story but
regardless of the scenario she's
basically on par with a silver surfer
here and it's cool because the idea of
the Celestials finally intervening and
beginning the process of trying to
basically destroy Galactus and ensure
the survival of this celestial seed
comes when Galactus destroys one of the
Celestials but something else that I
also want you guys to notice here is
that Reed is kind of in awe but he's
also harboring a bit of a secret because
where he sort of analyzed this whole
situation musing to himself talking to X
51 one of the things he says is that
Galactus is a compassionate being the
problem with this is that Reed Richards
didn't realize this until it was too
late and when the question is asked what
do you mean by that Reed says I turned
Galactus into a star and what that means
is that the Galactus here is not the
original Galactus and that begs the
question who is it and so that's why
this is so cool that's that's that's why
I've been dying to do this reveal I've
been dying to do this reveal for so long
because it is so amazing now the other
half of
remember Loki had basically discovered
that the Asgardians are essentially
beings who were formless they were just
kind of shape-shifting organisms that
existed out there one day and then when
they first encountered humanity humanity
viewed them as like Norse gods and
that's where the Asgardians came from
that's why we have Thor and Odin but the
idea that that Loki had realized this
whole situation that the Asgardians are
not inherently as Guardians meant that
he was able to rally the entire cause
because what he said is if the humans on
earth die then we will basically die in
our current form and so because of this
the Asgard he has basically intervene
and begin the process of jumping into
the conflict against the Celestials but
that that remains read actually takes
off from watching the Celestials
basically engage in battle with one
another and essentially goes back to
Medusa basically saying look the whole
reason why Inhumans returned to earth in
the first place was to look for the son
of Black Bolt and Medusa so they can in
turn marry the daughter of Quicksilver
and crystal the issue is that they've
been looking for their you know for the
son the entire time but haven't been
able to find him now earlier in these
videos we talked about the Black Knight
with that basically stood alongside
Captain Britain and we didn't know who
the Black Knight was and he was never
addressed that's when we basically
learned this is the son of Black Bolt
this is where he's been the entire time
he's been hiding under everyone's nose
he's basically just been perceived as
the heir of Captain Britain should
Britain ever fall and it's actually the
perfect idea just hiding in plain sight
but who's ever going to guess that the
Black Knight standing alongside
Britain's only real remaining super hero
is the heir to the inhuman royal family
so it is pretty smart not a great big
huge thing but it's just designed to
kind of wrap up the inhuman plot that
was going on with regards to this story
but again jumping back to Galactus the
cool thing is that the Celestials cannot
destroy Galactus I mean they could if
they wanted to but it would it would
upset the natural balance of things and
what this means is that if Galactus were
to be destroyed by the Celestials in
response to the fact that he's been
destroying Celestials themselves then
most likely what would happen is you
would have like The Living Tribunal up
here and the linee tribunal would say
this does not work Galactus represents
cosmic balance Galactus has to exist and
then most likely the Living Tribunal
would reconstitute Galactus and we would
be right back at square one again and so
if the result is that the cosmic balance
is maintained the Celestials ultimately
take off and even then it's not a great
big huge deal right like this is one
planet in a single solar system in a
singular galaxy in an infinitely
expanding universe losing one celestial
seed is by no means the end of all
things
earth is essentially irrelevant in the
greater cosmos of what is the universe
because that what we end up having is
Reed Richards who travels back to New
York and essentially like reaches out to
Galactus and basically calls out his
name and this is when we learned Reed
was the one who summoned Galactus and
the reason why Reed was able to summon
Galactus across the cosmos is because
Reed Richards didn't have like a device
he didn't have an artifact
he didn't shout the name Galactus what
he shouted was the name of Franklin and
that's when we find out Franklin
Richards is the new Galactus now this is
insane this is cool but again this is
one of those moments where Marvel kind
of built on this later on Jonathan
Hickman doing the whole like you know
Fantastic Four run and the idea that
like future Franklin Richards powers
were equal to the power of Galactus when
they had a huge conversation at the end
of the story and Galactus basically said
like we'll stand at the end of all
things it was kind of predicated on a
lot of the earth X stuff that was done
but the whole idea here is that Franklin
doesn't really remember himself being
Franklin Richards he sees himself as
Galactus and he operates as Galactus
Franklin realizes that he was called
Franklin and he finds it kind of strange
what reaches kind of like well you know
I just called you by the name of my son
because you know I love my son but he
doesn't really explicitly address
Galactus and say you are Franklin
Richards you are my son instead it's you
just remind me of my son I mean it is
Franklin but it is kind of cool that the
son of read the reality-warping son of
Reed would have sinned to the level of
godhood because in truth it's the most
natural evolution for his character I
would imagine if Galactus were ever
destroyed it would make sense that like
Franklin would take his place but what
you end up having is the celestial seed
destroyed inside the earth by Galactus
Galactus this basically takes off says
we will not see each other again this
will be the end of us following this
things actually wrap up pretty quickly
what you end up having is x51 machine
man basically realizing the truth behind
us who watch you The Watcher that not
only was he blinded by Black Bolt in
order for Black Bolt to basically hide
his actions when he had initially left
the planet Earth and given everybody
powers to the Terrigen mists but what's
also been going on is we watch The
Watcher can only really know what's
going on in earth by hearing everything
that's going on and so essentially what
happens is Machine Man comes along and
basically says like your race was
designed for the purpose of watching
things but you guys are apathetic over
the course of your entire existence
you've watched the Celestials plant
seeds in worlds create life on that
world or metal in the Olmedo with the
life on that world and then in turn
watch that world grow watch those you
know species kind of reach
dirty and then watch the Celestials show
up destroy everything and then give
birth to a new celestial and just repeat
the same thing time and time again your
entire existence has been nothing but
the sole purpose of just watching things
be destroyed that's kind of the cool
thing with machine man because what he
says is to do nothing in the face of
such evil that is truly heinous
but notices it's almost like it's almost
kind of like you know the idea of like
good and evil exists here but in this
scenario I would say a dozen I mean it
doesn't make any sense to say like you
are evil because of a inherent you know
natural drive that you as an organism
has the idea of celestial is planting
their seeds in a planet and then
manipulating the genes of that species
in order for them to protect the planet
and then in turn having that planet
destroyed when it when the celestial is
born that's no more evil than like the
wind blowing they play a role in the
universe they are a fundamental force of
the universe good and evil don't really
apply here and that's the cool thing is
because what this is designed to hit
home at is despite the fact that x51
machine man has watched all of this
happen and despite the fact that he has
all this experience and what it means to
like be human and to understand humans
at the end of the day he's not human
because he's trying to apply human
attributes of right and wrong to a
situation that doesn't call for it and
it's not applicable and so because of
this like the whole basis of machine man
kind of adopting these mentalities and
then in turn trying to use them on the
watcher really hits home at the idea
that at the end of the day when it's all
said and done he's no more of a man than
he was when he was first created he's
just walking the paces he's just doing
what people do and that's really about
it and so again for the most part where
the celestial seed being destroyed
society just kind of reverts back to its
standard standard form in the sense that
you still have people who wage war
against one another but because of the
fact that there was a common threat that
saw the near destruction of all things
that basically people begin to sort of
consolidate and come back down the world
begins to return back to a state of
normalcy form and function of organized
society begin to come back again the
issue with this is that in the middle of
everything
read kind of falls asleep or has a dream
sequence and he's suddenly met by marvel
all the Kree who had died quite some
time ago because of course in Earth X he
had died of cancer just like he did in
the main Marvel Universe him so when is
it happening is Marvel basically says
everything is about to change like
everything that you see going on here
none of its permanent everything is
about to go absolute belly-up the
Celestials were the least of your
concerns things are about to get a whole
lot worse and I'm here to save everyone
but you basically have to protect
to me you have to ensure that I will be
reborn into this world and that this
birthing process will go off without a
hitch now in truth he's basically been
kind of you know resurrected so to speak
as the child of hizmet and Adam warlock
and so again it's kind of cool to know
that's gonna happen but what this does
is it sets the stage for the events of
universe X and paradise X this kind of
trilogy of this alternate reality series
of stories they're interesting I mean
again I haven't read them in a long time
so I need to go back and read universe
and paradise but if you guys are
interested in seeing those let me know
down in the comments section I'm sure a
lot of you guys will say yes but if you
guys are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you